rob schneider was everywhere in the late
1990s in the early 2000s but since then
he's become a bit of a phantom only
popping up in films and on TV on the
rarest of occasions if you think it's
because Hollywood is avoiding him you
might be right
here's why Hollywood won't cast Rob
Schneider anymore box-office beat down
not telling the Adam Sandler movies he's
appeared in Snyder's flicks or anything
but critical darlings his best reviewed
film the animal only holds a 30% rating
on Rotten Tomatoes and earned a Marazzi
nomination for worst actor of the decade
at least nighters films tend to be
OneNote low-budget Affairs Rob Schneider
is a Wall Street executive with
everything going for you only problem is
he's about to become a carrot I'm a
carrot as a result almost every single
one of them earned back their budgets
still studios don't tend to be
interested in mid-level hits hiring Rob
Schneider is like buying store-brand
when you could be eating a real Count
Chocula for 50 cents more do you really
come out ahead discount bin material
while most people are aware of the deuce
Bigalow movies and the hot chick many
don't realize Schneider actually
continued to make films probably because
most of them went straight to DVD in
2007 he directed and starred in big Stan
followed by the chosen one in 2010 the
chosen one
yeah we've never heard of them either
even norm of the north in which
Schneider voice the main character was
regarded as a bomb it Schneider the
touch of death we're not saying he
definitely is but please if you DC Rob
don't let him touch you Lisa shut your
eyes soon you will be at peace
lawsuit magnet even though she Niners
movies tend to make their money back
sometimes the profits don't end up where
they're supposed to go investors
actually sued him for his 2010
straight-to-dvd release the chosen one
in an attempt to recoup their money
while lawsuits in Hollywood aren't
uncommon when you take into account the
lack of blockbusters in Schneider's
portfolio inviting lawsuits is really
just one more reason not to hire him
he's a bit player Rob Schneider may have
headlined a few movies but plenty of
movie fans find it hard to name the ones
that don't have deuce Bigalow in the
title and yet he's gained international
fame for his smaller roles like the
Cajun guy from Adam Sandler's the
waterboy in which he repeated one
sentence several times you can do it and
which he repeated in at least five of
Sandler's movies you can do it you can
do it you can do it you can do just
without you could argue Schneider is
little more than a one-hit wonder Ashley
making copies okay maybe two hits junk
science activist activism in Hollywood
is nothing new but when an actor weighs
in on a hot-button issue it's reasonable
to expect that it can have an impact on
their employment opportunities this has
definitely been the case for Schneider
who's outspoken opposition to vaccines
in support of a debunked theory linking
them to autism cost him his gig as a
pitchman for State Farm in 2014 there's
an unnecessary shot that they don't need
to have especially one of the babies
immune system isn't developed tweeting a
George Washington quote about freedom of
speech wasn't enough to get him his job
back but Schneider has kept up his anti
vaccine crusade claiming to be in
possession of a smoking gun report
proving their harmful later he was
accused of leaving a threatening message
for a California politician Lorena
Gonzalez who was working on behalf of
mandatory vaccine legislation he thought
Schneider was no laughing matter before
the Assemblywoman responded on her
Facebook page saying quote let's be
honest that is 20 minutes of my life
I'll never get back arguing that
vaccines don't cause autism with deuce
Bigalow male gigolo he's behind a
microphone more recently Rob Schneider
has disappeared from the screen to lend
his vocal talents to animated features
instead like the after mention norm of
the North died no time and the little
penguin pororo's racing adventure didn't
fare too well so Schneider is obviously
making some rough voice work choices so
while his face has become a rare sight
on the silver screen we'll probably hear
more from him in the future even if it
is in the sequels of the Kung Fu Panda
ripoff The Adventures of Panda war
no seriously that's a thing let's go
rescue princess Angelica thanks really
can if only we were making this up
there's like three different Kung Fu
Panda ripoff movies ethnic stereotypes
watch any movie featuring Rob Schneider
and odds are good you'll see him playing
some kind of ethnic caricature like the
Hawaiian hula from 50 first dates or the
Asian minister from I now pronounce you
chuck and Larry
cool with whitewashing controversies
becoming more of a problem for Hollywood
in general it makes sense he'd had fewer
opportunities to do just that especially
considering he's been accused of mugging
to the point of ridicule self employed
like a lot of other creatives Schneider
is leaving traditional film and
television broadcasting behind instead
he's taking his talent to the Internet
where you can do pretty much whatever he
wants in addition to a part in his pal
Adam Sandler's critically despised
Netflix fill in the ridiculous six
Schneider released a stand-up special
soy sauce in the Holocaust in 2013 as
well as the self produced series reel
Rob in 2015 at this point Studios can
rest easy knowing they don't have to
worry about hiring Schneider anymore
these days
he just employs himself not totally
hopeless despite not appearing in
theaters all that often anymore Rob
Schneider's career probably isn't over
he's keeping busy and a comeback of some
kind is still possible look if Mel
Gibson can do it just about anybody can
as long as we never see another deuce
Bigalow movie either way he seems okay
with where he's at here's my economics
I'm gonna go out to my $150,000 car
drive back to my two million dollar
house and hang out with my hot 29 year
old wife can't really argue with that
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
and watch more videos like the one you
just saw and don't forget to check out
all this cool stuff we know you'll love
to